you know what I miss I was thinking
about the other day musical chairs do
member musical chairs then whereas
school I don't even know when it
happened but about once every two years
some new legislation came down at school
and they once again allowed kids to play
musical chairs that's where they put
like seven chairs in the middle of a
room and they put like forty kids in the
room and it was just bonkers you
remember how crazy it was you remember
it it was like ah it was almost like the
Royal Rumble like WWF Royal Rumble and
they had everybody or suddenly ever you
start to see who people are you'd have a
little you know a couple sets of twins
these two females and brother over there
sharpening their teeth with the real
file you're like that you know these
[ __ ] getting a seat suddenly all the
white kids were like oh we're gonna have
a chance to do something athletic like
musical chair and then the music would
start all around the mulberry bush mmm
and people are just just I and the other
person suddenly a friend was not a
friend at all suddenly some kid he just
reached in his bag and his painted his
face up like William Walsh you know he's
like we all free tell them other kids
was getting scared one kid fainted bruh
dude whatever son you out bruh you out
you can't handle musical chairs ink on
the handle musical the rest of your life
then go move to somewhere else Brumby
week daddy we got to go
five ten ten ten ten and then it would
stop and be with you and people you'd
see some kid pull out a blade
you know some rich kid would bring a
chair from home you're like fauntleroy's
aha
that's it they had some pedos on the
side betting on it laying money you know
plus 750 on a little Reginald over there
and the teacher was smoking cigarettes
it was insane and thence just all these
cheeks flying it was but first it was
but first and there's just nothing more
just quirky and silly than a bunch of
children's butts all flying in the same
direction at once and you had to get
cheek to seat some kids they go for a
chair miss it completely shatter their
legs shatter their spine end up in a bag
on so you know end up travelling by sack
up for the rest of the lives on their on
their on their dad or mom's back if
their mom was strong just you know just
you had to get two cheeks on the seat
and it was yours
and you had somebody to be yelling in
the distance somebody be yelling cheap
that seat there's people crawl crawling
through pipes full of duty and they said
it would take a man 600 years so they're
all that same prison but musical chairs
Randall did it in less than 20 and you
know little Daniels back there in the
back he got him a little Santa sack and
he's not even playing he's just stealing
people's stuff I mean he's back there
he's taking these like just mom made
sandwiches and game boys and just
filling up a sack and he's just he leapt
out the window riding on the back of a
greyhound he left town that we never
even song cuz you know Daniel you know
he makes his own choices but damn boy
musical chairs
the game ends somebody it came down to
two people one chair and it was actually
kind of a great thing for regular life
this is regular life it's gonna be
survival of the of the of the fittest
you got to get that ass right because
this
cheak first sometimes you got to put
your ass on the line and one you know
somebody win you don't and that you win
in they supposed to give you some
candies and they go in the cupboard and
who know who's some little [ __ ] kid
ate all of them lime slices some sneaky
little white boy that polling Nicaragua
snacked up all the lime slices and
little Daniel he's already he's halfway
to Tacoma and he got that bag of you
know maybe lukewarm muffins and some ham
sandwiches and some pudding packs bro
and he's keyed up boy man I'm just I
mean it was God's game I mean it was
God's game man if you're watching on
YouTube did you enjoy that clip well you
really would have enjoyed it if he was
watching on a TCL TV TCL is America's
fastest growing TV brand it's so fast
it's the Carl Lewis of television brands
it's that Florence Griffith visual
jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com